a little like
thing i pull out and then i put a
squeezy tube down into my mouth and then
i can drink from a bottle just how
uncomfortable can wearing a spider-man
suit be every spider-man film has
boasted an extremely vibrant collection
of characters equipped with some
state-of-the-art costumes and makeup
from those tight spidey suits to those
gruesome villainous prosthetics the
stars of the spider-man movies had to
get quite uncomfortable when portraying
their on-screen personas i was just like
swinging about in this super creepy way
and like trying to
trying to talk to peter who wouldn't
want to suit up as spider-man it was our
childhood dream to put on the iconic red
and blue suit and that was no different
for star tom holland i feel like my
whole life had been leading up to me
trying on this suit despite the
excitement wearing the suit on set did
come with some setbacks in fact holland
believes that he has the hardest suit to
wear out of anyone in the marvel
universe whenever holland has the
classic suit on he's covered head to toe
in lycra with no skin showing i can't
even use my phone
and i'm 23 like i use my phone a lot in
fact polland isn't even able to scratch
an itch on his face in the costume it's
just one of the costs of being
spider-man it looks amazing it feels
terrible the costume designers behind
the mysterio suit wanted to make sure
that it was as practical as possible
since the bulky costume wasn't
particularly the most comfortable fit
the producers assumed that gyllenhaal
wouldn't want to be wearing the
villain's threads in too many scenes you
know it's like wearing a ball gown
grab your ba you're all of a sudden
choked by this right though gyllenhaal
was more than willing and even a little
excited to bear through the discomfort
and wear the mysterio costume whenever
he would see fit so not only is this
costume practical but he wears it
everywhere it makes sense to wear it so
we think this looks amazing
it took a little bit of time to put on
but once it was on yeah it made me feel
pretty strong it wasn't just alfred
molina who took on the persona of doc
ock director sam raimi wanted the
villain's trademark claws to actually be
practical effects which led to
puppeteers acting around molina to make
his robotic tentacles look more alive
molina needed to do rehearsals in
costumes so he could get accustomed to
moving around in the complicated suit
people understand how much the actors
are doing because you think oh it's all
magical cgi stuff topher grace had to
undergo a grueling makeup process to
become the iconic spider-man villain
venom for the third film in the original
trilogy i had four hours of prosthetic
makeup every morning when i was venom
and just getting on the suit takes about
45 minutes before that so i had to get
there at three or something grace also
had to go through an extensive workout
routine to gain around 20 pounds for the
roll
in order for dane dehaan to become the
grotesque and slimy green goblin the
makeup took over three hours initial
designs for the gross looking villain
had dehaan taking on an even greener
look as the iconic spider-man villain
but the makeup department decided to go
for a look that felt more slightly human
than full-on goblin that's how i started
out like you know playing pretend and
dressing up as superheroes dane dehaan's
goblin suit weighed 50 pounds and took
an hour to put on the set where de haan
was required to be in his goblin get-up
was over a hundred degrees fahrenheit
and because of the extreme conditions
dehan lost seven pounds in just two days
now that's impressive
jamie foxx had the distinct advantage of
having two distinctive styles as max
dillon aka electro in the amazing
spider-man 2 but it was his villain's
nerdy alter ego that was internally
painful for typically sleek and smooth
fox fox dubbed his hair on set as the
first black comb over and he also
sported a gap in his teeth when i was
max on the streets girls are like look
at jamie foxx at that hair oh my god
something is off with him at the same
time fox was at least somewhat relieved
that he wouldn't be as bombarded with
attention since he figured there'd be
plenty of people who wouldn't recognize
him honestly though most people would be
able to recognize jamie foxx no matter
the makeup hey y'all tell everybody
electro's in town the makeup department
behind jamie foxx's electro look had to
get very experimental in order to
prevent inhibiting fox's performance as
the blue skinned villain very thin
pieces of silicone were applied all over
fox's body in order for the look to be
much more believable on top of the
silicone fox had to wear glowing blue
contact lenses it was a great choice to
be in this film and i'm i'm happy and
fortunate that they that they chose me
while rhys
full lizard form was mostly cgi there
still was plenty of makeup work to be
done for the transitioning stages of the
villain ifans would spend up to seven to
eight hours in the makeup chair to
complete his green scaly look after
seven hours in a chair with not enough
cigarettes i was kind of in the right
mental state to play a man who was about
to transform into a nine foot lizard
with a dangerous tail the prosthetics
caused a lot of chafing on ifan's body
which led him to walking around like a
cowboy for several days after filming
after all there has to be some side
effects from becoming the lizard
marvel was extremely strict about what
holland was supposed to wear underneath
his costume during holland's first day
on set he was given thongs by the crew
as the only thing he could wear under
the spiderman costume i had serious
misgivings would my art ever be the same
again but i had to get used to it
secondly i have to wear
essentially pajamas michael keaton's
vulture suit stands out in how it
combines the classic marvel style with
something a bit more grounded i can't
tell you there are hundreds maybe of
little screws literally that special
wrenches made to put the boots in a
certain way a costume this intricate
took quite some time to fully equip on
heaton i don't know what my favorite
costume was because it's like what 7 30.
i'm barely awake i barely know where i
am andrew garfield wasn't necessarily
thrilled the first time he put on his
spider-man suit the suit he wore was
made of a material that was designed to
make you irritated on top of that
garfield suit was skin tight which led
to more of his body being visible to the
public than we would have preferred one
of the first nights we were out on
location in downtown l.a we were in a
parking structure i knew there were
paparazzi taking terrible unflattering
shots of my you know everything it was
an acting exercise
it was just a lot to uh to hold i i
struggled to hold it all i kind of
rejected it a lot rules were so strict
that holland claimed that even simply
drinking water in the spidey suit was
dangerous this led to holland and the
costume designers having to brainstorm
ways to adapt as obviously holland would
need some fluids while filming in the
heat
i can kind of get it i've had a kit kat
in the suit now the left eye on the
spidey costume would have a squeezy tube
attached that holland would have to pull
out and put into his mouth so he could
get a drink of water how refreshing
i loved in spider-man particularly
playing the double roll willem dafoe is
known for his very distinguishable
jawline so when playing norman osborne
in the first sam raimi spider-man movie
he needed to look more like how the
billionaire character looked in the
comics defoe was given dental
prosthetics to make his teeth look
straighter as the main villain though
the prosthetics were removed whenever
his character would look at himself in
the mirror and they were really fun to
do while willem dafoe surprisingly did
not need much prosthetic work done the
acclaimed thespian still had some
discomfort about the green goblin's
technologically advanced costume defoe
called his experience in costume severe
though he still had a great time on set
whenever tom holland put on that
spider-man suit he knew there was no
going back for him in many ways like
having to wait to go to the bathroom an
accident is not an option that suit is
so expensive they'll be so upset with me
in fact holland would have to plan going
to take a bathroom break 45 minutes in
advance hopefully there were no
accidents while filming toby maguire
wore the iconic red and blue spider-man
suit over the course of three films just
because he had a longer tenure as the
character than somebody like andrew
garfield that didn't make the suit any
more comfortable in fact the black
symbiote suit that maguire wore in the
third film proved to be the most
uncomfortable suit of them all it can
ride up in the crotch a little bit it's
not really the outerwear of the suit
it's the inner bit that rides up well at
least it wasn't flash thompson giving
the wedgies this time
toby maguire holds the title of being
the first actor to portray spider-man on
the big screen and with that the costume
designers were still trying to work
through crafting the perfect spider-man
costume in order to get the costume
right the designers had to do a full
body cast of maguire which wasn't the
most fun experience for the actor i had
to stand there for a couple of hours and
then the stuff sticking to the hair on
my body and they ripped it off and it
was extremely painful maguire even
initially had a hard time acting with
the spider-man mask on though he was
able to get used to it quite quickly
while andrew garfield's comics accurate
spider-man suit may have been a fan
favorite in the amazing spider-man 2 it
was far from comfortable for garfield to
wear it was a very specific experience
and
i imagine um
it'll be different every time garfield
blamed his british reverse on the reason
why he was uncomfortable in the costume
spandex does not suit the british you
are pretty much naked so you have to
trust what you have is enough
paul giamatti's rhino suit required
plenty of cgi but that didn't prevent
his onset appearance from being an
uncomfortable one in fact giamatti's
costume while filming required him to be
attached to a large metal-like structure
some of which he'd wear with backpack
straps
there's clearly a lot that goes into
making these spider-man characters look
as good as they do from hours-long
makeup applications to extravagant
prosthetics and uncomfortable costumes
the franchise's biggest stars were able
to power through their discomfort when
bringing the famous web head to life